aucun survivant dans le boeing 747 d'air
india qui s'est abîmé en mer ce matin au
large de l'irlande israël annonce sa
libération de 31 prisonniers chiites
mais les 40 otage de beyrouth sont
toujours aux mains de leurs gardiens
formule 1 keke rosberg et gagne le grand
prix de détroit probst n'a pas terminé
la course
cinéma nous accueillerons dans un
instant fanny ardant vedette d'un film
italien d'une jeune réalisatrice est
rien mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est
l'une des plus graves catastrophes
aériennes de ces dix dernières années
un boeing 747 de la compagnie air india
qui avait décollé de montréal et qui
devait faire escale à londres s'est
abîmé ce matin en mer au large de
l'irlande il y avait 3 129 personnes à
bord il semble bien ce soir qu'il n'y
aura aucun survivant
les causes de ce drame sont encore très
incertaine mais on n'exclut pas qu'une
bombe ait pu exploser à bord de
l'appareil
hélène risacher signal automatique de la
boîte 547 a été repéré tout à l'heure
par la marine irlandaise est droite et
la mémoire électronique de l'avion et
permettra sans doute de connaître les
causes de cet accident
au moins soixante corps ont déjà été
repêchés par les sauveteurs et placé
dans une chapelle ardente de l'aéroport
de cork au sud de l'irlande 15 appareils
avions hélicoptères anglais américains
et irlandais ainsi que plusieurs bateaux
ont participé aux recherches ce soir
seuls les navires continuent leurs
patrouilles mais les sauveteurs sont
très sceptiques quant aux chances de
retrouver un survivant
pour l'instant nous n'avons aucun signe
de vie les corps retrouvés ont tous été
tirées de lieux en avons trouvé personne
dans les gilets de sauvetage est une
véritable scène de bataille
il reste de l'avion couvre un rayon de
huit kilomètres autour de son point de
chute
preuve de l'extrême brutalité avec
laquelle le 747 est entré dans l'eau le
747 d'air india avait décollé de
montréal et faisait route vers londres
pour effectuer un ravitaillement avant
de repartir pour bombay le pilote avait
signalé son arrivée à la tour de
contrôle de shannon en irlande
huit minutes plus tard il a brusquement
disparu en une seconde des écrans radars
alors qu'il volait à 10000 mètres
d'altitude le pilote n'a lancé aucun
signal de détresse alors qu'un bouton
spécial sos se trouve à portée de sa
main
les 747 est l'un des avions les plus
sûrs du monde et l'explosion d'un de ses
moteurs est peu probable
de même pour un accident atmosphérique
qui aurait cassé l'avion reste donc
l'hypothèse de l'attentât
lors de l'escale à montréal trois valise
suspecte avait été retiré des bagages
en fait elle ne contenait pas
d'explosifs rajiv gandhi le premier
ministre indien a ordonné une enquête
le crash que ce 747 aura fait
semble-t-il 329 morts ce soir tous les
aéroports du canada sont en état d'
alerte renforcée car il faut ajouter que
deux heures avant la disparition du
boeing d'air india sur l'aéroport de
tokyo une explosion a tué deux personnes
elle s'est produite au moment où l'on
décharger les bagages d'un avion qui
venait d'atterrir alors il peut être
hasardeux d'établir déjà une relation
entre cette bombe et le boeing d'air
india mais on remarque tout de même que
l'avion de tokyo était parti d'un autre
aéroport du canada vancouver
véronique bonnet n'aura aéroport de
narita près de tokyo 14h50 heure locale
voyez des chars un conteneur de bagages
qui leur explose dans les bras bilan
deux morts et quatre blessés graves
beaucoup de casse matérielle c'est
probablement une bombe à retardement qui
est à l'origine de cette explosion qui a
eu lieu une demi heure après
l'atterrissage d'un avion de la canadian
pacific airlines cet avion transportait
3 142 passagers et curieuse coïncidence
venait lui aussi du canada de vancouver
malgré des dégâts matériels importants
les installations l'aéroport n'ont pas
été touchés l'efficacité nippone oblige
l'aéroport a donc continué à fonctionner
normalement sans aucun retard dans les
vols qui suivait l'attentât n'est pas
revendiquer à beyrouth dixième jour de
captivité pour les quarante otages
américains et peut-être enfin un début
de solution à l'horizon israël vient en
effet de faire un geste en annonçant la
libération de 31 17 166 prisonniers
chiites qu'il détient dans la prison
dany tu la libération doit intervenir
demain pour le moment nabih berry répond
que ce geste n'est pas suffisant pour
qu'ils libèrent les otages américains
mais cela montre sans doute en tout cas
que la négociation discrète qui s'est
engagée entre jérusalem washington et
beyrouth commence à donner quelques
résultats
gilles du jonchay l'essentiel était de
commencer et c'est peut-être ce qui
vient de se passer aujourd'hui la
libération des détenus libanais en
majorité chiite de la prison israélienne
date lite est devenu on le sait la
principale revendication posées par les
pirates de l'air de beyrouth
ces détenus qui avaient été arrêtés en
février au sud liban puis transféré en
israël jérusalem avait l'intention de
les libérer progressivement comme l
avait fait d'ailleurs le 29 mai pour 300
d'entre eux c'est le détournement de
l'appareil de la twh qui aurait empêché
la remise en liberté des sept cent
soixante détenus restants leur
élargissement ou leur maintien en
détention a été toute la semaine
dernière on s'en souvient au centre
d'une querelle entre israël et les états
unis washington voyant dans leur
libération une issue au problème des
otages américains à beyrouth jérusalem
de son côté s'y refusant tant que le
gouvernement américain ne lui offrait
pas la demande officielle
alors que s'est-il passé pour qu'israël
en viennent à libérer dès demain
31 de ses propres détenus ce qui serait
un premier pas dans le sens souhaité par
les états unis
beaucoup d'observateurs note que cette
décision a été prise par le cabinet
israélien peu après kamal ce matin à
beyrouth et menacé de remettre les
otages américains aux pirates de l'air
si les états unis continuer à faire
oeuvre d'intransigeance on remarque
aussi que jérusalem a eu recours à une
astuce juridique vont être libérés
demain les seuls détenus qui ont fait
appel contre leur détention devant les
tribunaux israéliens en invoquant le
fait qu'aucune inculpation ne leur avait
été notifiée dans les délais légaux
beaucoup d'observateurs pensent qu'il
s'agit d'un appel du pied à l'intention
des autres détenus pour qu'eux aussi
fassent également appel contre leur
absence d'inculpation faut-il rappeler
qu'il reste en outre quatre quatre
otages français détenus au liban et dont
on reste sans nouvelles parmi eux le
journaliste jean paul kauffmann et le
chercheur michel sera une grande
manifestation aura lieu demain à paris à
18h30 à l'appel de très nombreuses
organisations des syndicats et des
partis politiques de tous bords une
manifestation destinée à la fois
soulignent ses organisateurs à défendre
la liberté de la presse et les droits de
l'homme et enfin toujours à propos du
liban le secrétaire général du rpr
jacques toubon vient d'annoncer que deux
parlementaires de son parti vont
prochainement se rendre dans ce pays le
liban pour témoigner sur la situation
qui connaissent les chrétiens et pour
leur démontrer la solidarité des
français
au parti socialiste on s'interroge
toujours sur la façon de trancher la
discorde entre lionel jospin le premier
secrétaire et le premier ministre
laurent fabius bertrand delanoë
responsables des fédérations ou parti
socialiste qui était aujourd'hui
l'invité de midi presse sur tf1 estime
que ce débat est utile et en même temps
il dit qu'il sera solidaire jusqu'au
bout de lionel jospin
à paris quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont participé cet après midi à
deux rassemblements pour la paix
organisée par le comité de l'appel des
sens l'affluence était bien moins grande
que celle observée l'an dernier chantal
bretz
il était un peu plus de dix mille selon
la préfecture de paris 60 mille selon
les organisateurs
en tout cas on était bien loin des 250
mille personnes qui avaient répondu l'an
dernier à l'appel du mouvement de la
paix largement soutenu par le parti
communiste et la cgt
pierre juquin georges marchais henri
krasucki se trouvaient parmi ces
manifestants de tous âges
le parti socialiste ne s'était pas
associée au rassemblement jugée ambiguë
par le secrétaire national du ps
bertrand delanoë ainsi qu il le
déclarait aujourd'hui avant paris sept
villes de france ont connu depuis le
début du mois de semblable manifestation
les sept astronautes de la navette
discovery ont presque terminé leur
mission c'est à 16h15 demain qu'ils
doivent retrouver à terre la dernière
journée de cette aventure d'une semaine
a été consacrée aujourd'hui comme
d'habitude d'abord à faire le ménage
avant le retour dans l'atmosphère
ensuite à tenir une conférence de presse
en duplex avec le sol ce qui en
particulier nous a permis d'entendre le
français patrick baudry faire le bilan
des expériences scientifiques qui l'a
mené un bilan tout à fait satisfaisant
autant le plan équitable dans le
laboratoire attend des deux veulent
également et travailler plutôt combien
on en est réellement
avez vous un portait du vin bord de
discovery
puis j'ai inventé un peu de vin c'est du
très bon bordeaux mais je n'ai pas eu la
possibilité de le goûter
car ces échantillons de vins ne sont pas
dans mon sac de voyage contenant mes
affaires personnelles
je regrette de ne pas avoir pu déguster
ce très beau vin dans l'espace mais je
le boire et des mots retour à houston et
je verrai alors si son goût a changé
est-ce que vous pensez que
la navette américaine est la meilleure
façon de les explorer l'espace ou bien
où on nous faire mieux en europe avec
hermès avec arme est devant un thème
tout à fait divers et fera
complémentaire à la station spatiale
habitée cloud européenne ou américaine à
bord de laquelle nous travaillons en
coopération est important dans l'avenir
c'est justement de pouvoir rester le
rester longtemps pour y travailler et
d'avoir des stallions et qu'ils allaient
rendre les pour des voyages plus longs
atteint dans notre m et peut-être d'un
docu formule 1 un grand prix très
mouvementée cet après midi à détroit le
français alain prost n'a pas pu le
courir jusqu'au bout vainqueur keke
rosberg est derrière lui les deux
ferrari de johan scène et alboreto
dominique champeau on départ du grand
prix de détroit sénat gunman seul qui
sera le plus prompt au démarrage
il précède senna prost rosberg alboreto
warwick et de angelis qui fait
l'extérieur dans sa voiture noire
dès la première ligne droite c'est là en
valent tous les chevaux de la lotus
renault et d'autorité prend la tête des
opérations
mais très vite derrière lui va se
manifester la menace rossberg rossberg
fait des étincelles mais c'est celle à
qui aura les premiers ennuis
trahi par ses freins qu'il abandonne le
moment
et en profite aussi pour changer de vie
à cet instant les deux williams de
rosberg et man seuls font la course en
tête ça ne durera pas mansell emporté
par sa fougue ira au point deux fois
avant de s'arrêter définitivement cette
fois il rentrera à pied c'est plus sage
d'ailleurs les spectateurs qui avait eu
le nez de se poster à cet endroit vers
ont pensé du monde entre autres tambay
viendra y faire un petit tour et prosp
lui il fera ses hedge seul keke rosberg
déjoue tous les pièges montrant le point
quand les attardés ajoute à la
difficulté il est en tête est tout à
fait à son affaire à la mi-course
seul johan sun alboreto brundle et b9
suivent encore mais l'hécatombe
n'épargnant personne brundle et aliot
s'arrêteront sur une derrière chaleur
comme une inde elle est sûrement soulagé
devant rosberg est tout simplement
impérial alignant les virages et les
épingles il termine sa démonstration
sans être réellement menacer
joensson et alboreto donnant à fait ravi
les deux autres places sur le podium
alboreto conseil il aussi sa place de
leader au championnat mondial
cyclisme une surprise l'arrivée du
championnat de france qui se disputait
dans l'yonne sur le circuit de chailley
c'est un nouveau venu qui a remporté
l'épreuve jean claude leclerc un
français qui habitent la suisse
dominique champeau il s'appelle jean
pull bleu clair il a presque 23 ans et
s'il est seul en tête du championnat de
france et qu'il a pris l'habitude de
courir en suisse c'est là-bas en effet
que jean de gribaldy est allé le
chercher la saison dernière alors qu'il
terminait ses classes dans les pelotons
d'amateurs professionnels donc depuis
cette année seulement on le présentait
surtout comme un honnête grimpeur est là
aujourd'hui sur le circuit de chailley
dans l'yonne
on a découvert un véritable rouleurs on
pensait en effet que les velléités des
chefs de clans et de l'orgue et non à
l'arrière à les faire fondre son avance
comme une tablette de chocolat blanc pas
du tout leclerc écrase lui aussi les
manivelles et avec une ponctualité
d'helvètes il s'acharnera à conserver
une minute d'avancé sur tout ce petit
monde qui ce matin encore le connaissait
à peine les présentations durée 260 km
jean claude leclerc champion france ou
samedi
et
cinéma ce soir avec henry chapier nous
recevons fanny ardant que l'on va
découvrir dans un film italien de anna
maria tato c'est son premier film
s'intitule desiderio c'est à dire en
français désire tout simplement
fanny ardant il ya garde une sorte de
lady chatterley moderne un extrait du
film avant qu'on la retrouve avec henry
chapier
finir dans vous n'avez pas eu de mal à
tourner un film en italie avec des
italiens un film qui parle italien
ah non au contraire de tourner un film
en italie est une façon de se libérer
contrat parce que sur un tournage
italien il ya une sorte de joie et un
grand professionnalisme et tout ce qui
se passe à côté fait qu'on perd de son
trac on perd deux licences dramatique
des choses vous parlez lui devient mais
c'est ce que je leur disais toujours je
le comprends donc il fallait qu'il fasse
attention à ce qu'ils disent parce que
je comprenais tout ce qu'on donne à la
peau pour le film c'est vous qui perdez
ou on vous a doublé on m'a doublé et les
scènes je vais parler en français comme
tous les italiens comprennent le
français dans y avait pas de problème
alors fanny ardant moi je vais vous
demander quand même de nous livrer un
secret cette scène extraordinaire
combien de voir je dis bien qu'il était
ordinaire parce que des scènes de viols
dans les films
milliers mais celle là particulièrement
l été et les bouleversants vraiment
alors est-ce qu'on peut répéter une
scène comme ça et parce que c'est ce
qu'on vous demande toujours le public
lui demande comment vous faites il ya
une montée du désir il ya ces commandes
a je crois que c'est le metteur en scène
qui détient tout il ya que le metteur en
scène qui sait jusqu'où il veut aller
alors il propose il dit aux acteurs
alesi et en fonction de ce qui se
produit il ya des moments où il dit plus
d'un sens plus dans là et là on perd la
notion du raid de la real en février de
la réalité mais le fait que alain maillé
à tato ce soit une femme
est ce que ça ne rend pas plus facile la
communication parce que dans ce film
c'est important que le réalisateur soit
une femme et vous l'héroïne
il ya une complicité différente
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un homme non non moi
je crois place on s'était très bien
comprise avec un à maria d'atos et
qu'elle m'avait fait lire le scénario et
qu'elle m'avait dit n'ayez pas peur pour
cette scène ne s'agira pas se
déshabiller d'avoir une complaisance je
veux que ça soit suggérée alors à partir
de là je les faisais une grande
confiance
je me sentais pas en péril mais une
chose qui m'a étonné dans ce film
évidemment la part de la mémoire est
différente on sait que nous tous nous
subissons un peu notre enfance tout ce
que nous sommes et particulièrement le
personnage que vous jouez mais est ce
que finalement le désir ce fameux des
idées ailleurs faut-il un alibi pour
l'expliquer est-ce qu'il faut d'un alibi
pareil pour motiver le désir d'une femme
pour un autre homme
pourquoi cet alibi de la mémoire ah mais
je crois que la mémoire de sa jeunesse
son enfance vient après coup c'est ce
grand moment désirent un contrôle et
injustifiée qu'elle ne veut pas
justifiées qui a fait sauter certaines
barrières et comme elle est dans un
péril puisque elle pense avoir tué cet
homme est lettrage il est temps fragile
ayant recueilli cette petite fille sur
la route tout s'ouvre tout arrive en
vrac mais quand elles rencontrent cet
homme
c'est une femme qui mystérieuse dans le
sens où on ne sait pas vraiment sa vie
d'avant et elle subit cette chose comme
ça alors je vous poserai aussi une
question peut-être un peu agaçante
on a le sentiment dans tout le film
qu'on a voulu aussi nous donner le
portrait de ce qu'a été le sort d'une
femme italienne
dans ce pays deux coques très fier que
sont les hommes italiens
et puis la femme toujours quand même un
peu recluse pas tout à fait comprises
moi je trouve que si on a voulu donner
une image du sort des femmes italiennes
dans ce film elles doivent être heureuse
parce que c'est une femme libre
finalement elle est arrivée d'une
enfance où sa grand-mère était marquée
par une certaine chose sociale
sa mère encore prise elle donc on sait
ce qu'elle a vécu
elle est partie c'est une personne qui
travaille et elle est libre elle assume
tout ce qu'elle fait
yg oui son désir complètement
complètement et elle en sort presque
plus fortes pluies plus épanouie
complètement oui alors si ça peut
arriver à toutes les femmes italienne
banco merci seigneur et de films sort
donc mercredi les résultats du tiercé
qui se disputait aujourd'hui à auteuil
la combinaison gagnante 6 13 et 4 les
rapports dans l'ordre 4487 francs et
dans un ordre différent 640 francs 50
pour 5 francs
le temps demain ça me change guère
toujours de la pluie et des nuages
entrecoupé de quelques rayons de soleil
sur la majeure partie du pays seules les
régions proches de la méditerranée
seront à peu près épargné les
températures elles resteront de nouveau
demain basses pour la saison pas plus de
16 à 19 degrés au nord de la loire 20 à
au maximum dans le midi demain soir vous
retrouverez soir 3 à 22h25 avec richard
tripot dans un instant au cinéma de
minuit
edwige feuillère dans la duchesse de
langeais et avant cela je me rappelle
les principales nouvelles de cette
journée excellente soirée sur la trois
pas de survivants à la catastrophe du
jumbo jet d'air india qui s'est abîmé au
large de l'irlande il y avait 3 129
personnes à bord israël relâchera demain
31 prisonniers chiites mais des 40 otage
de beyrouth
toujours aux mains de leurs gardiens
mission réussie pour l'équipage de la
navette discovery ils atterriront demain
après midi
à